indeed even though magic as a concept is
often looked down upon as unlam by many
in the Islamic world today these kinds
of talism can very commonly be found in
a Middle Eastern Market or in the homes
of people stemming from this region I'm
sure that many of us have seen the
protective amulets against the evil eye
that can be bought in bazaars in
Istanbul or seen the very famous and
often beautiful hand of Fatima Adorn the
home of a friend or family member these
are all examples of Talis manic magic
and has always been a major part of the
culture in the Islamic world this is the
same phenomenon something that exists
across a wide span of different cultures
not just the Islamic world